go yourself Chris L your baby and bl up
your ass your own biscuit fat ass that
have told me that my parents deserved to
die in a car accident because
I'm little baby Wing is off you
Chris there's that people don't
understand I knew a kid who had Tourette
so I watched his Tourette's evolve from
where he was in grade school and it was
you know he'd be writing doing taking an
exam and he go that was it and then it
translated to grabbing my eighth ra
girlfriend's ass to be clear Tourette's
is obviously a thing only 10% of people
have Tourette's blurred out obscenities
I don't know the rate on them actually
like doing the up yours motion or
hailing Hitler as part of I had a girl
who wouldn't talk dirty and but I turned
her in for a girl touret oh my God it
was tremendous